it's me again I want to talk about
magnesium did you realize that 57% of
population is deficient in magnesium
it's mainly because they don't eat
enough leafy greens but magnesium is
found a deficiency of magnesium is found
in 80% of heart attacks so it's really
important in the cardiovascular function
because where calcium controls the
contraction of the heart magnesium
controls the relaxation of the heart
okay and so magnesium clears out that
calcium so then you can relax so you
always need them in proper ratios so if
you're deficient in magnesium you tend
to get arrhythmias and that could be
anything from a skip beat to an extra
beat to an abnormal beat to a flutter to
fibrillation atrial fibrillation to a
palpitation where it's a little
hesitation all that electrical rhythm
sort of speak the pacemaker problem
would be magnesium and then we have
hyperirritability I mean what about
like hyperactive kids oh my gosh right
here or hyperactive adults that just
can't wind down cramps muscle cramps
cramps of the heart angina pain right
here spasm of the arteries that's
coronary constriction this is great for
it help you sleep at night
because it's a calming mineral soft
tissue calcium so what happens magnesium
helps lower the calcium buildup in the
body so yes vitamin D and vitamin k2
will also help it but magnesium is
another key mineral to help balance the
excess calcium in your body so if you're
deficient magnesium you could have a
tendency to have more Spurs you can have
arthritis bursitis tendinitis calcium on
the eye is cataract kidney stones gall
stones tartar on the teeth calcium
buildup on the nerve a little twitching
called tetany that's magnesium
deficiency and then we have high blood
pressure because magnesium is supposed
to relax and calm things down people
take it for constipation as well to help
relax the muscles in your colon and if
you're deficient you may be it might
have memory problems or learning
disabilities or you're just
learn as fast as you would like okay so
that's that's the effects of magnesium
secondly what causes it
okay what causes a magnesium deficiency
mainly the diet because people don't
consume enough leafy greens it's also in
nuts it's in seeds it's in a lot of
other foods
it's in eggs but mainly it's in leafy
greens I get my magnesium not from a
pill but from a food based concentrate I
use the wheatgrass juice powder because
if you look at chlorophyll chlorophyll
is like the blood of the plant magnesium
is the center element like our body you
use blood with iron that's red but
magnesium is green and that's what the
plant uses as its chlorophyll and so I
consume concentrated so wheatgrass juice
powder 1tsp gives me all the magnesium I
need and it's a real calming mineral so
it's even good to take before bed so
diet is an important thing stress
depletes magnesium magnesium helps
reduce cortisol magnesium reduces
adrenaline yeah amazing
vitamin D deficiencies so you need
vitamin D not just to absorb calcium but
to absorb magnesium yeah
alcohol will deplete magnesium diuretics
will deplete magnesium anti acids you
need a strong stomach to absorb
magnesium and all minerals by the way so
if you have acid reflux that means you
have not enough stomach and you take
antacids anti anti anti acids you're
going to not be able to absorb those
minerals so acid reflux really is not
enough acid and so the valve doesn't
close and the acid shoots up and you get
heartburn so that means you need to
acidify the stomach so you can fix that
valve and then absorb the minerals so
really one of the clues for stomach acid
is does the person have acid reflux yes
okay then no wonder they're not
absorbing the minerals magnesium
especial
so taking like tums and things like that
or antacids okay so I hope you learned a
little bit about magnesium and
definitely apply this information and
write your comments below